you guys know i like catch phrases but
what you're talking about is conduct
that is detrimental
and that's a term that's used often in
our business and appropriately so
uh because in this code environment if
you're not exercising discretion and
being thoughtful about how you move
that conduct is detrimental to your
cause and to ours collectively
and so that's the messaging that i'm
delivering to those guys
um you know we got to conduct ourselves
accordingly there's been a lot of work
to position ourselves
to be where we are right now um you know
it's one fail all fail in this
environment and so we're going to
continue
to package the messaging that way um and
be very transparent
it is that this conduct detrimental to
their efforts and ours
well it's coach mike tomlin from earlier
in camp chris and look at it this way
this deal has had no one opt out they've
had no one on the covet 19 reserve list
they waited until july 28 to let anyone
in the building they were taking the
full time to get it ready
they're practicing out of heinz field
where they have four locker rooms that
they can use
to spread their players out watch week
one
i guarantee you they're going to travel
same day to play the giants like they
did eight years ago when they couldn't
get a hotel because of hurricane sandy
they're going to travel same day
they're going to take care of business
they're going to come home they're going
to continue to keep
everything as tight and protected as
they can this is an opportunity for mike
tomlin
to reconfirm why he's one of the best
coaches in the nfl
yeah and he's gotten his guys committed
and believing in that full season
sacrifice you need to make
in order to master this challenge of not
letting the
pandemic get into your building no doubt
well i mean there's there's
you know you could argue he's the best
at messaging in the nfl he's one of the
best of messaging i've ever been around
you know i mean just all you got to do
is listen to those comments there i mean
he just
the way he always lays it out on a daily
basis
i've always been impressed with mike
tomlin that way even in just
normal conversations like me and him man
to man
you know seeing him at the owners
meeting or something like that
like some of the things he'll say to me
i'm just like man that was
well said or that was really eloquent
with the words there
and made a lot of sense it hits hard you
know it hits home that way
and that steelers team as you know mike
they got a lot of alphas on that team
a lot and that is a team where i feel
like if you're a young guy and you're
messing around and gonna mess up their
season
they will set you straight in a hurry
and within those alphas too
you know hey yeah we've had the antonio
browns and some guys that you go damn
he's a pain in the butt but they've got
guys that love football there in
pittsburgh too
and that's why i think you see alphas
love football
love to hit love the attitude of it you
know
and that's why they have no opt-outs and
uh yeah they're one of those teams i
look at and go be both i think
go watch out for them this year i think
the crowning achievement of mike
tomlin's coaching career will end up
being the fact that he was able to keep
antonio brown from having the implosion
that we've seen over the last 18 months
in the 10 years that they were together
in pittsburgh getting the most
out of abe's talents ben roethlisberger
back he is now entering year 17
as the steelers starter missed most of
last year with that elbow problem
i i still am concerned and the reason
we're talking about the steelers are
number 11
on our preseason power rankings we're
working our way to the top we've got 10
left the steelers right on the fringes
of the top 10.
they could end up being really good this
year one of the key ingredients will be
whether or not
roethlisberger is number one recovered
from the elbow injury and chris number
two
whether or not last year was just the
first thing to go bad
on a car that's in the process of
breaking down that's my concern
okay the elbow went and the elbow's
fixed
and that's all well and good but what
about the knee
what about the hip what about the
shoulder what about
every other body part that is taking a
beating on this guy
for two reasons number one he takes a
lot of physical abuse
when he's on the field yeah number two
when you are carrying around more weight
than you should
every day you get out of bed and walk
around and move around and run and do
anything
is putting more stress and pressure on
those
body parts and after you've done it for
all these years
it may be time for things to break down
that's my big concern
that the elbow wasn't the end that the
elbow was just the beginning
hey big ben um uh mike florio's
concerned about your weight
he's just so you know he's just a little
concerned he's lost weight he's calling
you overweight
big man he's bored no i'm not wait a
minute wait a minute
no he was i know i got you he was
he is he is a large man you're right i
mean he's one of those guys that if he
had a bad weekend
and you know drank ate too many
roethlisberger
sandwiches there in pittsburgh or
whatever he could probably put on eight
or ten
pounds he is a naturally really big guy
but
you know i those concerns you're talking
about yeah i'm worried about them too
you're right it's been a physical brand
of football over a long career
uh now you know
i really think though just as far as the
quarterback play being able to throw the
football
all of that i expect to see the old big
ben i do
i i don't think he's passed his prime
yet
to me he looked good last year you know
obviously just
had the issue of the elbow but i didn't
sit there and go
oh this doesn't look the same you know i
know they didn't start off great but i
still saw
you know popping the ball and a guy that
could still thread the needle and do all
those things so
it's good they got him back and really
in pittsburgh the offense is the
question right mike i mean
that's the question you know who are the
receivers that are going to help big
bend out who's going to rise who's going
to be the cream of the crop there
you know it is as a james washington
take the next step does the deonte
johnson take the next step to help out
of juju smith-schuster
does my man chase claypool who i think
is a
could be a superstar can he do it here
in year one
you know those are the questions we have
and then the running game i mean really
i don't we don't even have to talk about
the defense the defense is special
but those are my biggest concerns about
them going forward i don't know
how you feel about that no look
hey last year they didn't have
roethlisberger antonio brown or le'veon
bell
and it showed and they still almost got
to the playoffs yeah without those guys
james connor took a step back we had the
draft last week of the guys who need a
hot start most in the nfl james connor
needs one or he's going to be on the
bench for benny snell or anthony
mcfarland jr
or and jalen samuels a nice pace guy
that's going to get his opportunities
the receiver position let's start there
because we've got different position
groups and we're going to rank them
whether they're in the top third of the
league the middle third of the league or
the bottom third of the league let's
start with the receivers and this one's
the easiest for me
you got to put them in the bottom third
right now because too many guys are
unproven
last year they tried to make juju's
misschuster into a number one he's not a
number one he's a great number two
he's not a number one because he can't
stretch the field and it showed in his
production last year
you double him you can take him away and
then you can focus on the other guys and
none of the
other guys stepped up enough now look
without ben rothersberger there
it's hard to tell where they would have
right but all things all things
taken together i i think that that that
receiving core has the potential to get
much better this year but somebody's got
to step
up it can't be like it was last year
somebody's got to fill the shoes
that were vacated by antonio brown when
he went into the
cryogenic chamber without shoes on last
year and that started his spiral
downward in oakland but uh
uh yeah so i think for now they're
bottom third and i think that's a fair
somebody's got to be no i think that's a
fair assessment of where they are
yeah i i don't think you're crazy to say
i don't know if i would say bottom
third i think i probably would maybe say
the middle third
i guess is where i would go you know i
understand just like you have 20 top 10
receivers
if you started listing the receiving
cores you would you
would run out of spots before you got to
the steelers yeah well
again i don't i don't know if we saw
you know exactly what the receivers are
to your point with no big bend there
okay so i i think james washington you
know
he showed me some moments last year on
oh damn i mean he kind of started to
look dangerous
and deante johnson that way too you know
and also
just with the receiving core and i know
this is not within the spirit of what
we're talking about
but you know again yeah juju i'm spot on
with you there i think juju proved to me
and i know big ben was out there and
that was hard but he's a
he's really a really good awesome number
two he's not a number one
you know so yeah can chase clay will
come and be that guy you know
like i said i have never seen too many
people in all my life around football
that are like chase claypool
i really think he has a chance to be a
superstar but also to throw into that
conversation
you know the tight end play eric ebron
is there you know vance mcdonald they're
good too
so i i throw them into that mix just at
least as far as weapons are concerned in
the past game
that make that receiving core a little
bit better but but
your questions are real i think they
have the potential to be a top third
though maybe by the end of the year
as i think is what you're saying but we
to just see it on the field especially
with ben back yes especially with ben
right right it may change everything
having been back a great quarterback
can make a receiving core a lot better
than it otherwise would be
perceived as performing at all right
offensive line top third middle third
bottom third we've got
alejandro villanueva who's been an
anchor there at left tackle
stefan wisniewski at left guard marquis
pouncey at center david dicastro right
guard and matt
feller at right tackle where would you
put that offensive line right now in
year two
without uh mike munchen coach the hall
of famer mike munchak
i was thinking mike malarkey mike
munchek mike munchek is now
in denver for for the second year and uh
without him it's been different
where do you put them i i think middle
third you know i think two years ago
like when we had the end of the levy on
bel air pittsburgh was
in the conversation for the best
offensive line in the nfl
but you know guys have aged yeah
pouncey's getting up there
you know villanueva's getting up there
david decasio are still a really good
guard
you know but but uh again
you know the other guys yeah good
players but this is not like the
dominant front we saw
a few years ago where le'veon bell could
have a hole and then ben roethlisberger
you know could have time to
you know sit back there and pat the ball
and wait for antonio brown to run some
30-yard intricate route or something
like that
yeah right now i think they're middle of
the pack which we saw also affect
you know their run game and things like
that they're kind of at that time where
they're going to have to start thinking
about retooling their offensive line
getting it a little
younger and started up again here
because i think there are
you know coming down to the the end of
the shelf life for this offensive line
here very soon
and and here's the thing when they won
two super bowls with roethlisberger as
the quarterback
their offensive line was clearly
right right right it was horrible it and
and it was amazing that they were able
to get it together
and play well and win playoff games and
win super bowls with an offensive line
that was that bad
it was only you know in the past several
years since mike munchek yeah
mike malarkey showed up in pittsburgh
that they started to have a great
offensive line
so you know it's still in that range
where it's good enough especially
because
the rest of the team especially the
defense
is getting back to what it used to be
the steelers went through a stretch
where they were heavily skewed toward
the offense
after being years of skewed toward the
defense and now it's balancing out more
so the offensive line doesn't have to be
elite and dominant it can be middle of
the pack and that could be good enough
and let me flip over to the front seven
on that defense top third middle third
bottom third for that group
oh i mean top third all the way uh i i
there there's no like stopping me with
that comment there
i mean to me that's it's easy it's
really almost like is it a top five
you know and i think it's really into
that conversation too right mike i mean
when you start to get into it yeah they
lost javon hargrave that stinks
they got chris wormley from the
baltimore ravens he'll be able to fill
that role he's pretty damn good
stefan tuitt cam hayward i mean maybe
the best pass rush duo in football in my
opinion a lot of the draft earlier this
week with dupree and watt
and then the middle linebackers and
vince william and
and bush the first round pick for i mean
damn that is like special
i mean it really is they can do whatever
you want that can hunker down and stop
the best offensive line on fourth and
one
or they can get after the quarterback
and you know harass him all day in the
past game so definitely
in that top five-ish conversation for me
yeah i agree with you the strength of
the team now the reason why they were
still
alive into late december last year and
almost achieving one of the most
unlikely playoff appearances
in recent history with that offense that
was in
shambles without roethlisberger bell and
brown and nobody to really step
up and fill the void the defense has
filled that void so the defensive line i
agree with you clearly
clearly top third if not top five in the
nfl when you factor in the front seven
as well
secondary where would you put them you
know i
and and for years when the defense was
great the secondary was it was it was
okay the cornerback play was never
over the top not since rod woodson great
safety play
right now where would you put that that
uh quartet
of uh members of the second day i think
like realistically
it's middle of the third middle third in
the nfl
you know you of course they got two
really good safeties i mean minka
fitzpatrick can be a superstar
and we saw what he can do last year you
know j you know you know uh
joe hayden still a solid player you know
they got a lot of
good at corner no great you know i don't
look at joe hayden as being great
anymore
this locked down guy but to me this is
where it's a little tricky like so
talent wise i would go
yeah i really think it's the middle of
the third talent-wise secondary
but with the scheme and what they do
creatively
and then like to mis mix and match the
front seven at times
you know it makes their secondary a lot
better
there's no doubt about that and they do
some off-the-cuff crazy things where
mike you and i could sit down and watch
film and
seven out of ten plays we could sit
there and go um i'm not sure what do we
call this coverage i don't know what the
hell this is this blitz why this guy is
dropping here
they voided this area so they're a game
plan specific type defense that way
and they use a little trickeration to
help out their secondary which
is why they can get away with the middle
third secondary in my opinion
the arrival of mickey fitzpatrick last
year when he was the first one to say
in miami i want out i want off this
sinking ship and he never felt like he
was used right by the dolphins
the steelers pounced and and you know
he's on track to becoming that next
great
steelers defensive player in the
secondary
the heir to a troy paloma dating back to
the guys like the troy woodsons of the
world the carnell lakes of the world i
mean
great defensive backs that they've had
and it's never been
across the board great but it doesn't
need to be when you're front seven
it can be as suffocating as the steelers
has been from time to time over the past
30 years
you don't need to have hall of famers
across the board and i think they're
good enough and they're right on the
fringe for me
between middle third and top third
right and i i have a feeling that at the
end of the season
we're going to be putting them in the
top third based upon how this team plays
all right best case worst case
pittsburgh steelers 2020 go
whoa best case i mean
best case super bowl
yeah i mean i you know best case right
like i
i i certainly like if we're sitting here
in early february and we're going oh
the pittsburgh steelers and ben
roethlisberger back in the super bowl
i'm not gonna be like oh my gosh i would
have never thought this day was gonna
happen
this defense is a super bowl defense you
know big ben staying healthy
offensive line we talked about it's an
aggressive system they need some of
those weapons yeah i'll say that
that's the uh utmost now the the floor
you know mike where the floor to me
is man like maybe last year
just they they gotta win week week 17 to
get in the playoffs and
they don't get in that's to me as worse
as it can get
but like i i look sit here and go i
think i'm going to be surprised that the
pittsburgh steelers aren't in the
playoffs this year i know that much
yeah look i i think you're right the the
best case is the super bowl the worst
case is the seventh seed because
i think with and to get that extra spot
is going to make all the difference in
the world in december there's gonna be
teams alive that we didn't think we're
alive it's gonna be a scramble for that
last spot
even if that team ends up being cannon
fodder for the two seed
and there will be a time when the seven
seed beats the two seed because there's
no bye week for the two seed anymore
so i i think at a minimum they're in i
think this is the first team
and and it helps that we're getting
toward the top ten i think this is the
first team where we've agreed
that the worst case scenario is still
playoffs yeah right i'm saying the worst
case scenario is missing out but
yeah but i i i think the worst case is
seven seed
if there were only six it would be just
missing out with seven i think they're
getting in even if everything that
happened last year happens again this
year yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports